hello and welcome to this video playing
FM h sk yo let's see what's in store for
this game i already have to get niture
the yeah the hang of online five minutes
i haven't played for more than a week
just having returned from the german
juniors championships where I was
working as a as a coach one of the key
wishes for the team of my my region him
on all the patina it wasn't a team event
but for the players of that area ok
let's see I think I had tried stuff like
that o in earlier games let's see how
this works out him Queen to have three
using this the spin on the bit on the
night yeah we'll probably just aged six
no again but interesting we'll see how
it works out yeah this video is going to
be released Monday the twentieth third
and um yeah i'll be online later on that
monday for my live show after not not
having had a show last week due to my
coaching activities so what is going to
happen here he's takes a turn okay i
guess he takes and maybe he's shooting
form um
for some be five and wonder if this is
actually an idea for Bishop b5 Queen B 6
Bishop b5 yeah that that looks okay I
think Bishop takes Knight takes seems
very okay 93 King into where that
doesn't lead to anything and I'm
probably threatening light c4 here to
just take this sex huh why is that a
move just wondering I don't understand
the move just has to go back check I can
take with the Queen here I can take the
shot actually hahaha so I'm not winning
winning serious material Justin just a
pawn I think okay that it's it's good
it's good to win a bond so where'd you
get to go now keen to d3 maybe 90 756
watch f3 maybe a 97 @ x that porn as
well
not one hundred percent sure what's bad
a king of 30 qd3
I mean why this better in both cases but
I wasn't really sure what's the better
the better of the two I'm material a PN
I have got very strong Center points
interesting move yeah but not c4 should
be should be good
I have a pretty bad score against the
sky mine is free yeah what's the deal I
mean he basically has to take it or not
what is the stay any alternative I
really don't see another move I mean
otherwise it just takes you three I
guess curious yeah that's probably
because why I don't have a good score
against them it's the kind of guy who
plays moves that I don't consider at all
I maybe rook c8 that still does that
still something where you can try to
arrest me keep the night there for a
moment
okay as I wants to play as complicated
as possible I cannot go 'if I've yeah
unfortunately which would be very nice
to get in I'm going to probably have to
take even though that's not ideal of
course I'm three pawns up now but they
are not very strong and the pawns so see
getting something back and maybe is
ninth day probably wants to go Roxy to
him ok back with the bishop
let's see how to do this Saudi six or
something looked you one and then d 67
yeah something like that maybe okay
takes it probably I can't have to do
this not quite sure what the ideas we
should do it's not possible
okay five maybe but not anymore okay my
this Ruby aid is a pretty good reply to
that so what's the deal he is so tries
to take this okay I'm going back check
check and check okay so I've grabbed you
more points um no gets this one and to
trade a rook time morning check check
cannot take it Ruby six wins the bishop
black resigns yeah so we tried to
somehow muddy the waters but it didn't
really work out the move 93 was very
strange I mean why does probably better
him anyway but 93 is just basically
giving that way I don't quite understand
it King into is the obvious move and now
he only has schneider/for which is very
bad for black or nights if I bag which
is also bad positioned like this is
looking really bad like I've got this
strong night good night see for coming
and he's got no counter play whatever
with the dispute their check and TM
Genesis ending is basically winning you
just have to be precise not sure if I've
played it in the best way but ok the
engine gives night c4 is even more
convincing and yeah it is probably very
strong but I don't think that this is
this is bad either yeah this is also a
plus and plus 2 position I just have to
make sure that I'm not blundering stuff
check why did a reasonable job there I
am could the engine is always some plus
free and check around this area rook age
fault so was strong with check check
check check I think that was that was
okay I think the main issue here was for
so opening play not quite sure at which
pointed I think probably until here I
think this is fairly reasonable for
black but the position that I get now
after this and there's this is pretty
awful it's blacks counterplay as I as I
said earlier this is basically
non-existent and then he played this
strange move yep i don't i don't really
like likes position he's super sir
the engine wants to play Queen d 8 which
is I mean this is dad this is just very
horrible the two nights totally dominate
on the Korean side you cannot open up
the position it's pretty awful okay well
thanks for watching